the jurogan experience nor macdonald
at one point was a handsome guy but he
lived on a farm with his grandpa
in the middle of nowhere so i don't
think he got the handsome love
yeah he's a [ __ ] great guy he's my
hero i love him to death
fun maybe one of the funniest guys on
the planet david tell norm
in that this something about those two
national treasures
i agree and and the fact that he's not
like the biggest comic of all time
is weird well he is to us i guess so the
comics i mean he's not the biggest but
the comics he's on the mount rushmore
keeps getting bigger
i know four heads is not a good enough
you gotta stop using that thing
yeah it's a bad thing to say the mount
rushmore but uh in the hall of fame
hall of fame the thing there you go yeah
he's in the hall he's like on another
level where he's invented
certain things i never knew like he's
he's taking comment to this higher
point which i didn't know existed hmm
that's a i wish i could come up with an
example another guy too that still does
real comedy like he when he goes on
stage he's still
he's [ __ ] ballsy yeah he swings right
you know like right
and he gets confused if everybody's mad
like what's happening yeah
just a joke here folks he keeps it real
he's uh i don't you don't have to pull
this up because it's long
but there was a radio show like a
morning show like you do on the road
for press and he's doing one and he's
like well you know black people they're
poor
and the lady is like oh my god how can
you say that norm that is so racist like
i'm not i'm reading the newspaper i'm
watching the news i'm looking at the
stats they're poor
and she's like oh my god and all these
black women call in they go
norm's right we're [ __ ] poor it sucks
and he's like you see you see it was
such a great moment
what what radio show is this it's on
youtube i don't know it's just some
[ __ ] and jizz in the morning you
know one of those things don't like him
doing things when he was doing his
netflix show
oh yeah someone specifically did not
want him doing interviews
because he got on the howard stern show
and he wanted to say
well if you think that way you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] right but he didn't he
didn't want to be offensive so
well you think that you must have down
syndrome he thought that be the better
thing to say
i guess everybody is i'm not sure yeah
everybody started freaking out
like that he said that right instead he
thought he was like
covering his tracks right right right
and so he couldn't do interviews after
that yeah he's brilliant
i mean the little things like the he's
just one of those guys who describes the
most basic [ __ ] that we all know
but it's funny when he because he points
it out like his letterman set the last
letterman when he goes uh
yeah yeah germany decided to attack the
world
you know and you're like that's so true
and then he goes who do you think you
are mars
i mean it's just so funny those little
things where he's just telling you
facts and it's funny yeah well he's uh
he's a unique dude you know there's a
lot of unique people in this uh weird
art form have you hung out with them
yeah i've never hung out with them i
hung out with them twice
accidentally on two separate occasions
the airplanes planes i told you about it
right i heard they are the one of them
and smoking yeah that's hilarious as
soon as he landed
he was talking about how great it was to
quit smoking as soon as he landed he ran
into the gift shop and bought cigarettes
and was lighting them before he was on
his way out the door
i go i thought you quitting was i did
talking about it i wanna smoke
yeah he just does what he wants randomly
on two occasions i just was sitting next
to him on a plane
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience